what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
now this is part two of two of this
video
if you missed part one make sure you go
back and check out part one first
because that dives into exactly how we
designed and documented this building
before we bring it into twin motion
so we've completed our architectural
model in archicad we're going to open up
show all 3d and go back into our 3d
model
as you can see we've completed all of
the architecture and we're going to take
it straight into twin motion
so what we're going to do is go up to
twin motion and go direct link
once twin motion opens up you're just
going to go into a new project
click ok and let it synchronize and do
its thing
straight away we're going to see a few
issues against our image in the
background
first of all the background itself is
completely wrong so we're going to go
down
to settings location background
city mountains and there we go straight
away we've got our mountains happening
in the background
if we drop down a little bit we can
probably rotate that
about 20 percent to have the peaks over
here if not even more
85 looks really good we have that peak
right there just like they do
the surface itself i think is a little
bit too high so we're gonna go minus
three to drop that
three meters below our building we're
going to open up
the panel on the left hand side to
change the starting ground
from whatever these brick pavers are to
water
so my recommendation is materials scroll
all the way down
water pull two and
straight away we're now starting to look
a lot more
like this image because we're hovering
above some water
it is a lot more crystal clear and blue
but we'll come back to the image once we
set up
our actual instagram shot of this as
well
so working on the actual building itself
before we get into the context we want
to change the material of this wood
simply by going into wood i would select
ipa
ipea and change the color
straight to gray and go into more
rotation 90
so now we're starting to look a lot more
like the image on the left hand side
we want to come out of wood go back into
metal go
brushed aluminium on these eye beams and
change the color
somewhere down the bottom near the black
it's not too important
just so it isn't black per se the
concrete itself inside is a lot darker
so we're going to come back out
go into concrete and select fine
concrete fine concrete slab gives us
that nice
dark black base it's probably a little
bit too dark so we'll just lighten it
that
tiny tiny bit and most of our interior
is already done
we do want to start creating something
nicer inside
so i do think that we need some
bookshelves
some better furniture and little bits
and pieces
so to replicate what we see in the image
on our left we're going to go into
object
home living room storage
and probably use this shelf here
so i'm going to rotate that 90 degrees
and bring it right next to that bed now
it doesn't touch the ceiling in this
instance
so we're going to tab through these
settings and these arrows here and go
1.25
to drag it all the way to the ceiling
we're still not quite there yet so if we
undo
go 1.3 a little bit too high 1.27
should be perfect now i'm also going to
replicate that one more time because
that bookcase does extend the whole way
along the bed
so by dragging that arrow pressing the
shift key simultaneously we can
duplicate this
so i do want an instance of that and i'm
going to change
the material as well to change the
material of any object you just come all
the way to the start of this
palette on the left hand side open up
your materials select the material that
you're looking for
me for instance i want plywood
probably twice the scale and a little
bit more orange a little bit more
warm compared to what it is now i do
also want to use that plywood for the
kitchen
and the bed as well the bed
unfortunately doesn't have any linen on
it it is a little bit basic
so we are going to replace it with a
twin motion bed
going all the way into our objects and
beds we could go back into archicad
delete this bed and
drop a new one in so if we wanted to do
that you just go into archicad
find your bed so
click it delete twin motion direct link
again
and it will synchronize and completely
remove that bed so now we can drop
a brand new bed somewhere in its place
there use that plywood again on the
bottom
select the material pick up so we can
change the color of the doona to white
like it is in the image and throw that
on the rest of the bed as well so pretty
quickly we're starting to replicate that
image we have the shelves we have the
bedding
we just don't have the chairs i don't
think twin motion has
any chairs even close to that so if we
go
all the way back out objects home living
room
chairs we can have a look at what twin
motion has
again it definitely doesn't have
anything similar but
i guess any chair will really do it'll
be a placeholder more than anything so
i'm going to use these ugly red chairs
bear with me for a second because i'll
use those chairs
take this material pick up select that
plywood again
and give it a plywood chair look
so now i can also drag that in a better
position
hold shift to replicate it and
rotate it minus 90 degrees so those two
chairs face each other
now our bed is sticking out a tiny
little bit through
the glass i'm going to just move it a
little bit
back in towards the shelf i think the
last thing we really have to do for the
interior of this building itself is just
place a human in the corner
so if we go back out to our library go
to characters i just want a posed human
for this instance
and i think the best option in this case
isn't really going to be identical to
that image
but i think this image of father and
daughter
very lovely together overlooking the
water would be quite nice
so i'm going to place these two right
into the corner of this suite
they look very happy they look like
they're having a blast so
that is probably an even nicer photo
than what we have
on the left hand side now obviously our
building is very much so
floating in mid air so we want to create
some context
so it doesn't look ridiculous the best
thing to do
go back out all the way going go into
vegetation landscaping rocks
and use rock 14. now i know that looks
like a cliff
but we're going to tab through that
again and reduce that to
0.5 in scale bring it down
into the water rotate it
as we see fit so
now we're just going to bring it in
front of our building here
as best as we can lowering it
adjusting it however we need to so it
looks like that building is
floating off the edge so now looking at
it from a low angle it does look like
that
rock face is all the way across what
we're going to do again
is simply hold shift and replicate a
copy of it this time i'm going to rotate
it a
bit on its axis so it falls away from
the water
and isn't directly as sharp as the last
one
so by simply rotating and playing with
the settings we can have that rock face
fall away however we want
in this instance it's falling away into
the water
something along those lines and we're
having a very similar
cascading effect like we have on the
image itself
now to make sure this doesn't look like
it's just floating in thin air one more
thing that i like to do is take rock 14
rotate it 90 degrees
and use it as an actual base so i'll
bring that
over and underneath this building here
bring it up a little bit and bring it in
so it looks like we have a base over
here
and then i'll copy a couple of these
across
so we again have some more rocks
and some more ground to actually play
with so
there is my cliff face that i'm going to
be using
now we can still see one small little
rock under that
beam over there so if i fly closer to
this building
and drop rock 9 directly under it
without losing it completely
i'm going to have to scale up that rock
to about 3
and there we go we have a nice rock
sitting underneath that beam there
okay so now that we have everything set
up for the context unfortunately
the downside of having this object is
you can't actually paint on some grass
so we're going to lose that grass effect
in this image but that's okay
we're going to start setting up our
actual instagram
export so if we go into media go image
and create new
it doesn't matter where you create it
because we're about to mess with some
settings
we're going to go into more format more
and change
these two dimensions to 4000
by five thousand i know it still looks
funny
bear with me back into image one into
camera and change
field of vision from 90 to 18. we're
also going to drop the vignetting while
we're here
and we're going to go back into image
one
zoom out as best as we can and now try
line up what we see in that instagram
photo on the left
so i think if we line up the edge of
that window as best as we can
the man is standing about halfway
through the water in the mountains in
the background and the sun
is peeking through that spot there
somewhere about
there is probably about right so we're
going to
recapture that image go into more
go into location again and change these
time
settings as best as we can to try
replicate that sun
peeking through that window now twin
motion is going to have a fit if we do
put the sun through the window so we're
going to just try poke it just to the
right hand side of it okay so i found
perfect settings are 6 20 june and
78 north offset but because it's
obviously blurring right through that
screen you can't really do anything
about it i'm going to push it to about
80 degrees offset so it's
just here and maybe if i play with that
a little bit more we might be able to
get a more
consistent setting but i think these
settings overall
for this situation work quite well what
you will see is it is a lot lighter and
a lot more blue compared to the natural
scene we have right now so if we come
back into image go back to more
and adjust our lighting settings we can
drag our white balance
all the way to the bottom to get that
light
bright feeling coming through similar to
what they have over here if we want to
bring this out in
twin motion and not take it into
lightroom i still i'm going to take it
into lightroom in this tutorial just to
get the most out of this image but we
come back into lighting
go into settings and bring up the
ambient all the way so we can actually
start
seeing this detail here and inside the
building as well
what i do want to change before we go
any further is the color of this water
so at the moment you can see it's that
dark blue but we want to make it that
kind of icy
frosty light blue like they have over
here in this image
so these are kind of the settings that i
think work for the time being
it's probably a little bit darker and a
little bit more blue but
that works for now now what we can see
is in the background our mountains are a
little bit
too nice and clear whereas they have
quite a bit of fog
so if we go back to our media more and
go into weather
we can go into effect and adjust our
smog
so we can just see that mountain fading
out in the background we can add
it quite heavy which i actually really
like that but that's not the
vibe we're going for in this image so
we'll bring that down to about
55 i think works well in this instance
so now overall i think our image is
ready to export there isn't too much
left that we have to do we could
potentially drop in a little small
boat in the background so if we go
vehicles boats
um let's see what small boats we have
they're all quite
large and absurd but if we chuck a small
little inflatable boat
in the background somewhere about there
we have something very similar to what
they have in
their image as well so i'm to quickly go
file
save as so i don't have any issues with
exporting i highly recommend you save
many times throughout this because twin
motion is notorious for crashing
unfortunately
so this image is pretty much finished in
twin motion
and we're gonna export it by simply
going to export image
image one export straight to the desktop
in this instance
okay so that took an absurd amount of
time to export and it just kept crashing
continuously but we
finally managed to export it out and
this is our image before we take it in
to lightroom so the comparison on the
right hand side here with the cliff on
the edge
the water the mountains in the
background we're getting quite close
i think the color grading is off is
what's really throwing these images off
so we'll minimize this one here and open
up lightroom
okay so now we have our image imported
into lightroom
and we're going to go over to the
develop tab
i've already imported all of my presets
directly into lightroom so it makes it a
hell of a lot easier just to change all
of these settings very quickly
if you want to check out the presets
there is a link down in the description
they're incredibly cheap and they just
help me out as a creator
so i think personally the perfect
setting for this is autumn external
straight away we get those nice blue
colors coming in
we don't really have to touch too much
if we drag that back to the side window
and open up this on the left we can see
that the colors are quite similar
the blues of the water is quite similar
the boats there the sun's coming in the
sky is very similar
and all we did was activate that preset
very quickly
to get all that information out of that
image
extremely quickly and there we go guys
that is the completed process
taking that instagram image that we
found online
into archaea24 modeling it completely
and then bringing it over in
to twin motion finally we exported it in
to lightroom to be able to color grade
it and make those scenes
match as much as possible but now we
have a phenomenal image that is very
similar to the one we saw online
if you enjoyed this video today make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below
and as always i will see you next monday
now i just want to take a quick little
break here and a quick pause
to mention something very exciting on
this channel this channel has been
growing
phenomenally well over the past couple
months as i'm producing more and more
architecture content you guys are loving
it so
thank you so much for being a part of
this community and helping this channel
grow
because of all of your support i've been
able to reach out to one of my premium
brands that i love working with so if
you look at my past
12 months of videos if not even longer
you'll notice that i'm always wearing a
black shirt
and most of the time if not 99 of the
time it's more than likely a cut
shirt i've been wearing cuts for a good
year
and they've genuinely been the best
shirts i've ever purchased in my life
so i decided to reach out to them and
see if they were willing to partner up
on this channel
to be able to help me produce better and
better content every day so if you're in
the market for the highest quality
shirts in the game
that are just so buttery and soft and
smooth and the second you put them on
you
know they are absolute premium quality
there's a link down in the description
below if you don't want to or you're not
in the market
that's absolutely okay i just genuinely
appreciate you guys being on this
channel
learning and producing better
architecture